hello everybody welcome to the very
first episode of David shows fashion
review for the 2016 Met Gala young
[ __ ] now what do I know about
fashion you ask haha absolutely nothing
now as you all may know when it comes to
Hollywood they always have their version
of who they believe are the top 10
best-dressed people of these red carpet
events that us peasant [ __ ]
aren't even allowed near and in fact
even if we could afford that $30,000
ticket
we weren't even invited because we're
aren't important funds at this event we
saw many new designs from the newest
ensemble and from designers such as
Dolce & Gabbana booth we can be perhaps
Valentino
but Banana Republic gap and once again
you asked do I know [ __ ] about fashion
absolutely not but neither do you've
done [ __ ] so without further
ado here are the top 10 best-dressed at
the 2016 Met Gala
first up Solange Knowles here we have a
girl who decided to walk outside looking
like a bottom of a [ __ ] muffin
wrapper whoever sponsored you to wear
that must be laughing his or her ass off
because you look like a pile of crumpled
up garbage if you don't know who she is
some of you might know her from her most
recent work ah yes you got 99 problems
and a Solange is one on a side note mr.
lunch I'm scared of you please don't
beat my ass this is just a joke and next
up we have Lord nothing much to say
about what Lord was wearing but why she
look like she don't know where the [ __ ]
she is they told her to look into the
camera but she said [ __ ] it i'ma steal
this child soul and of course nothing
says Madonna more than if she's on a red
carpet and her damn beautiful titties
are out perky Bravo Jaden Smith not as a
joke was probably one of the most
best-dressed that night I'm surprised
the young man wasn't dressed in a Dookie
thong with a bike lock stapled to his
dick try taking one picture with your
mouth closed huh looks like you're
waiting to catch some [ __ ]
flies and of course we had the very
beautiful Michelle Monaghan and her
fancy on some can't say Michelle doesn't
care about the earth because she showed
up to the gala as a sack of recycled
garbage bags Lupita Nyong'o
I like you
fan nothing much to say about the dress
but just to let you know your hair looks
like a big fat between Beyonce Knowles
hello I'm a huge fan and in fact I wish
you would adopt me like Angelina Jolie
does those Southeast Asian babies but of
course you came out stylin looking like
a caramel lollipop left out in the Sun
why did somebody decide to dress you as
flesh zoe saldana I'm also a huge fan
I'd pay someone a good amount of money
just to have you step on my face but
here she comes down that wonderful red
carpet dressed up in a Dolce & Gabbana
2016 version of C garbage as you can see
your designer decide to [ __ ] up a flock
of peacocks and dress you up as a big
mistake next up we have Jennifer Hudson
amazing vocalist and a positive voice in
the weight loss community and might I
say that you decide to dress up as the
[ __ ] I clean my windows with girl elect
a tail of an arctic fox she look like
she died and came back as a ghost to
hunt her grandchildren and last but not
least we of course have Lala Anthony she
has a beautiful voice suited for radio
and recently started up her acting
career as Satan's main squeeze
looking like Lucifer's side chick well
everybody this concludes this year's
review of the 2016 Met Gala I hope you
enjoyed it and for those of you that
didn't know the theme of this year was
technology did many people miss that
mark of course they did except for
Orlando Bloom who showed up in a nice
touch Osito suit and a ton of [ __ ]
gachi nailed it hey what is going on
YouTube yes that was a topic suggest by
one of y'all and if you guys want to
suggest more topics that's news articles
opinions whatever lists rants or
whatever you want is gonna be at David
so comedy connect at gmail.com email me
there and I won't get back right to you
and yes you will get a shout out if you
get picked by the topic yes people were
working together I'll see y'all next
time check out these [ __ ]
videos next to me